PROFESSOR: Next is this
phenomenon that when
you have a wave
packet and it moves
it can change shape
and get distorted.
And that is a very
nice phenomenon
that takes place in
general and causes
technological complications.
And it's conceptually
interesting.
So let's discuss it.
So it's still wave packets.
But now we have to go back
and add some time to it.
So shape changes.
So we had a psi of x
and t is equal to 1
over square root of 2
pi phi of k e to the ikx
e to the minus i omega of kt.
And what did we do with this
to analyze how it propagates?
We expanded omega
of k as omega of k0,
which, again, this quantity is
centered and peaks around k0,
plus k minus k0 times
d omega dk at k0
plus 1/2 k minus k0 squared, the
second omega, dk squared at k0.
And it might seem that
this goes on forever.
And what did we do before?
We looked at this thing and we
did the integral with this term
and ignored the next.
And with this
term, we discovered
that the profile moves with this
velocity, the group velocity.
Now we want to go
back and at least get
an idea of how this term
could change the result.
And it would change
the result by deforming
the shape of the packet.
So it is of interest to know,
for example, how long you have
to wait before your packet
gets totally deformed,
or how do you evolve a packet.
So we need to recall
these derivatives.
So the omega vk is the same as
de dp by multiplying by h bar.
And this you'll
remember, was p over m.
The edp is p over m and is
equal to h bar k over m.
So the second omega, dk squared.
I must differentiate the first
derivative with respect to k.
So I differentiate the first
derivative with respect k.
And now I get just h bar
over m, which is quite nice.
And the third derivative,
the 3 omega, dk cubed, is 0.
And therefore, I didn't have
to worry about these terms.
The series terminates.
The Taylor series
terminates for this stuff.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: The
reason this happens
is because we're [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So of what is it that we get?
Well, this term is roughly
then 1/2 k minus k0 squared
times h bar over m.
And we can go back
to the integral
that we're trying to do.
We don't do it again
or not by any means.
But just observe
what's going on there.
And we have an e to
the minus i omega of kt
that we did take into account.
But the term that
we're dropping now
is a term that is
minus i omega of k,
well, whatever we have
here, 1/2 k minus k0
squared h bar over mt.
That's the phase that
we ignored before.
But now we'll just say,
that we expect, therefore,
that the shape doesn't
change as long as we
can ignore this phase.
And this phase would start
changing shape of the object.
So our statement is going to
be that we have no shapes.
So let's imagine you
started with a packet
that sometime t equals 0.
And then you let time go by.
Well, there's some numbers
here and time is increasing.
At some point, this phase is
going to become unignorable.
And it's going to start
affecting everything.
But we have no shape change,
or no appreciable shape change,
as long as this quantity
is much less than 1.
So as long as say,
k minus k0 squared
h bar over m absolute value
of t is much less than 1,
no shape change.
Now it's convenient to
write it in terms of things
that are more familiar.
So we should
estimate this thing.
Now we're doing estimates in a
very direct and rough way here.
But look, your
integrals are around k0.
And as you remember, they
just extend a little bit
because it has some width.
So k minus k0, as you
do the integral over k,
you're basically
saying this thing
is about the size of
the uncertainty in k.
So I'll put here
delta k squared.
Then you'll have h bar t
over m much less than 1.
Now h bar times
delta k is delta p.
So this equation is also of
the form delta p squared t
over h bar m much less than 1.
There's several forms of
this equation that is nice.
So this is a
particularly nice form.
So if you know the uncertainty
and momentum of your packet,
or wave packet, up to
what time, you can wait
and there's no big deformation
of this wave packet.
Another thing you can do is
involve the uncertainty in x.
Because, well, delta p
delta x is equal to h bar.
So we can do that.
And so with delta p times
delta x equal to about h bar,
you can write t less
than h bar over m
over a delta p
squared, which would
be h squared delta x squared.
I think I'm getting it right.
Yep, so t much less than m
over h bar delta x squared.
That's another way you
could write this inequality.
There is one way to
write the inequality
that you can
intuitively feel you
understand what's happening.
And take this form a from a.
Write it as delta p t over m is
less than h bar over delta p.
And h bar over
delta p is delta x.
So you go delta p over mt
much less than delta x.
I think this is understandable.
Why does the packet
change shape?
The reason it changes shape
is because the group velocity
is not the same for
all the frequencies.
The packet mostly moves with k0.
And we haven't rated the
group velocity in k0.
But if it would have
a definite velocity,
we would have a
definite momentum.
But that's not possible.
These things have
uncertainty in momentum.
And they have uncertainty in
k that we use it to write it.
So different parts
of the wave can
move with different velocities,
different group velocities.
The group velocity
you evaluated at k0.
But some part of the
packet is propagating
with group velocities that are
near k0 but not exactly there.
So you have a dispersion
in the velocity, which
is an uncertainty
in the velocity
or an uncertainty
in the momentum.
Think, the momentum divided
by mass is velocity.
So here it is, an
uncertainty in the velocity.
And if you multiply
the uncertainty
in the velocity times this
time that you can wait,
then the change in
shape is not much
if this product, which
is the difference of how
one part moves with respect
to the other, the difference
of relative term,
is still smaller
than the uncertainty
that controls
the shape of the packet.
So the packet has a delta x.
And as long as this part, the
left part of the packet, then
the top of the packet, the
difference of velocities
times the time, it just still
compared to delta x is small,
then the thing
doesn't change much.
So I think this is
one neat way of seeing
what an equation
that you sometimes
use in this form, sometimes
use in in this form--
it's just things that you
can use in different ways.
So for example, I can do
this a little exercise.
If you have delta x equals 10
to the minus 10 meters, that's
atomic size for an electron.
How long does it
remain localized?
So you have an electron.
And you produce a packet.
You localize it to
the size of an atom.
How long can you wait
before this electron is just
all over the room?
Well, when we say this
t, and we say this time,
we're basically saying that
it's roughly still there.
Maybe it grew 20%, 30%.
But what's the
rough time that you
can expect that it stays there?
So in this case, we can
use just this formula.
And we say the time
could be approximately
m over h bar delta x squared.
It's fun to see the numbers.
You would calculate it
with mc squared over h bar
c times delta x over
c, this squared.
The answer is about 10 to the
minus 16 seconds, not much.
This is a practical issue
in accelerators as well.
Particle physics
accelerators, they
concern bunches, a little
bunch of protons in the LHC.
It's a little cylinder in
which the wave functions
of the protons are all
collimated very thin, short,
a couple of centimeters short.
And after going around many
times around the accelerator,
they always have to be
compressed and kept back,
sent back to shape.
Because just of diffusion,
these things just propagate.
And so it's a rather
important thing.